[Music]
we dug up the ages and some interesting
tidbits about our favorite cast members
of dissonance 2 and we can't wait to
share them with you watch until the end
to find out who the youngest cast member
is if you love descendants - as much as
we do subscribe to the things channel to
be the first to see our latest videos
and if you're a true dissonance fan
click the like button below now here is
our list of descendants two cast members
from oldest to youngest
Sophia Carson Sophia is the oldest
descendants to cast member on our list
her birthday is April 10th 1993 which
makes her in Aries this astrological
sign shows that Sophia is a strong
person who is quick to take action this
dissonance to star is very accomplished
and wicked smart
Sophia graduated from UCLA with a major
in communications and a minor in
broadcast journalism
she is also fluent in Spanish and French
as well as English BMI records must have
loved this because they signed her as a
singer and songwriter in 2012 this girl
is on fire
it's no wonder Disney cast her to play
evey in the films she is a classically
trained singer and is trained in several
dance forms such as ballet flamenco hip
hop modern dance and tap Sophia is
someone to keep an eye on watch for her
in the upcoming freeform TV show Pretty
Little Liars the perfectionists booboo
Stewart booboo Stewart who plays the
role of Jay in The Descendants films
comes next
his birthday is January 21st 1994 this
makes him an Aquarius Aquarians are
known for their originality and
versatile personality seems pretty
fitting for booboo doesn't one
interesting thing we discover about him
is that he considers himself to be a
yo-yo master he shared in an interview
that he used to be really into yo-yos he
said he had a lot of them he doesn't
pretty cool trick he calls a rocketship
mini fans no boo boo from his twilight
days for he shared the spotlight with
Taylor Lautner as a fellow werewolf he
also is an accomplished martial artist
who has won two World Championships and
was inducted into the Junior black belt
Hall of Fame pretty cool boo boo jae-in
descendants too is our favorite role he
has played yet Thomas Doherty
here comes hottie hook or excuse us we
mean Harry hook Tom
Dougherty is the next cast member on our
list Thomas's birthday is April 21st
1995 which makes him a tourist a tourist
he's known for the determined and stable
nature but this bull sign can also be a
bit stubborn want some fun facts about
Thomas here we go he was born in
Scotland but he currently lives in
London he is obsessed with the TV show
stranger things and has seen ma Leland's
seven times in theatres but the film
that has impacted him the most is the
Dark Knight Thomas says it was through
that movie that he learned it's morals
that dictate who we are and how we
conduct ourselves in the world Thomas
believes that if you don't have strong
morals you'll be lost hmm interesting
coming from a villain whose sword fights
on pirate ships mental hope metal hope
who plays mouths beloved Ben is also
roughly the same age as Thomas Dougherty
his birthday is June 27th 1994 this
makes him the cancer in the zodiac
cancers are sensitive sympathetic and
affectionate that seems to fit right
before booking the role of Ben in The
Descendants films he almost quit acting
he said his agent asked him to just
please audition for one last role first
and the rest is history
can you imagine anyone else playing the
part of cute lovable Ben in the films
because a we can't as it turns out
Mitchell is not a trained dancer like
his cast mates he said Kenny Ortega and
Paul Becker helped him figure out
different kinds of moves from using
sports techniques whatever it is it's
working Mitchell is from Melbourne
Australia and he is super outdoorsy he
loves to go on hikes his favorite
pastime is playing baseball and
apparently he's a huge Chicago Cubs fan
dove Cameron she's 22 years old and a
force in Hollywood we're talking about
Deb Cameron who plays now in The
Descendants movies her birthday is
January 15 1996 so that means she's a
Capricorn
Capricorn's are known for their
intelligence and discipline they are
also very loyal and good problem solvers
because they tend to think quickly no
wonder she can play the role of mouth so
effortlessly this Seattle native was
originally born with the name Chloe but
change is dove after her father passed
away he used to call heard of or dubby
and she wanted to honor him
so she legally got it changed when she
started acting so sweet
Dov is fluent in French according to her
Twitter post her family is crazy French
and they go there a lot
her mom wanted her to have two feet in
her family's culture trade bow to a bone
china and McClain our second two
youngest descendants cast member is
China and McClain the actress who plays
the wickedly awesome villain kid Ouma
was born on August 25th 1998 that makes
her a Virgo which means she is probably
known for her quick wit discipline and
generosity when China's not acting she
is performing with her two sisters
Sierra and Lauren in the singing group
mcclain the story of how she got her
name is pretty cool apparently when her
mother was pregnant with her she was
hoping for a boy but she found out she
was having a girl shortly after she was
watching a television special which
highlighted how families in China are
only permitted to have one child with
boys being favored to carry on the
family name
her mother decided right then and there
to name her baby girl Chyna
that's awesome Cameron Boyce that brings
us to the baby of the bunch Cameron
Boyce he's the youngest of the group his
birthday is May 28th 1999 making him a
Gemini Gemini is notorious for being
organized efficient altruistic and
empathetic that works very well for the
character of Carlos in The Descendants
films Cameron has raised over 27
thousand dollars for the thirst project
an initiative that brings clean water to
underdeveloped countries that's
impressive this generous Disney star is
also biracial which he has talked about
on social media he talked about his
mother he was Jewish and how impactful
it was when he visited the Anne Frank
House for Black History Month in 2016 he
shared that his grandmother Joann voice
was one of the Clinton 12 meaning she
was one of the 12 black teens that
attended the first integrated public
school in the south in 1954 those are
some incredible roots and we're not just
talking about his hair and that's it for
our descendants to lists of stars from
the oldest to youngest thanks for
watching the things channel bye
[Music]